now you know I recently tweeted believe
no women and you know maybe there's a
little bit of satire but the point of
the matter is we are supposed to live in
a society that is innocent until proven
guilty but time and time again
organizations treat men that are accused
of crimes as guilty until innocent and
my question is should we hold the
companies accountable that fire these
men before they are given a trial and
jury of their peers it's one thing if
the men are found guilty but they're
firing and removing men from
organizations and institutions before we
even have a verdict is that fair to the
men and do you think we would have that
same energy if women were accused of a
crime if women are accused of a crime do
you think that they would be so quick to
remove us from organizations and
institutions and the answer is no